to to introduce the first speaker and
childs who will uh talk about
uh a problem that actually he he
proposed
at one of the brainstorming sessions of
of the simon's program last spring and
some nice discussion followed it up and
and then the wizard
which we will hear about this uh
symmetries graph for participators
relapse
yeah thanks very much uh honor so um
it's a pleasure to be able to tell you
about some of this work
um yeah so this is uh joined work indeed
with unders
along with um uh my other co-authors
shall have been david william kreshmer
sapartha potter and douchion wong
and um you know some of this work was
done kind of separately from the
simon's program but as anders mentioned
some of it was done
kind of in response to an open problem
session that we had there
you know during the um you know during
the program and it was really you know
uh great to have the chance to to um you
know talk with andership about it there
and to
uh you know really make some progress
actually on this question so i'm going
to tell you about sort of the the plan
is to kind of tell you about the context
for the work
in general and sort of the setting that
we care about and sort of
say what the main results are but then
to give a little bit more detail on the
particular stuff that we actually
um you know worked on you know there at
simon's um
although maybe not that much detail but
we can always sort of you know follow up
with some
some discussion later and there's a
preprint that gives a lot of details
um you know uh if you're interested in
reading it i would expect i would
you know recommend you go there okay so
um the kind of general question that
we're interested in um you know is this
is this question about the power of
quantum computers um and
you know i think i don't have to really
introduce this um you know very much to
this audience
uh you know it's really a kind of a
basic question about about quantum
computers to understand
you know what are the problems for which
they can give us significant speed up
and as as you know there are some
problems for which we
um you know we can get exponential speed
up or or we think we can get you know
exponential or at least super polynomial
speed up
over the best um classical algorithms
and in some cases depending on the model
we can even prove that we get
exponential speed up
and on the other hand you know there are
other kinds of problems for which we get
um you know some speed up maybe but only
polynomials speed up
of course there may be some other
problems for which we don't get any um
you know significant speed up at all
um but you know a really basic question
is why why is it like this you know what
are the
uh what is the reason for some problems
having this very significant speed up
and others
you know um not having significant speed
up somehow
you know we need a problem for which we
can organize the interference in a
quantum computer
in such a way that it allows us to find
the solution quickly
and somehow that's not a feature that we
can take advantage of with a classical
computer
so you know i think there's kind of a
general understanding now that
um you know problems have to have a lot
of structure for quantum computers
you know to be able to take advantage of
that structure to get significant speed
up
um and sort of the um the goal of this
work is to try to
you know make that more precise to try
to understand better you know what are
the kinds of structures
that allow for significant quantum speed
up
okay and we're going to consider this
question in the setting of query
complexity which i mean i think this
model is probably familiar to
many of you but um you know this is a
this is a useful model
for exploring the relative power of
classical uh
and quantum computers because uh
partially because it's feasible to prove
lower bounds in this model
so so in this model um the input is
described by
a black box that somehow has some string
you know hiding within it but you're not
allowed to directly
um you know just kind of read that
string you're not just given the whole
string
rather you have to make queries to the
black box to learn anything about the
string
so what you can do is you can query a
particular specified character of the
string
and the black box will tell you what is
the value at that position of the string
and in on a quantum computer you can do
this in in quantum superposition in sort
of the
standard way and then the the question
we're interested in is how many times do
we have to query
you know how many positions of this
string do we have to query before we can
learn some property of the input and in
this talk we're just going to be
interested in sort of
you know answering yes no questions
about the about the black box input
okay now we can define you know um sort
of different versions of this of this
notion of query complexity depending
upon the
specific model of computation that we
care about and um
you know in particular we can use this
model to compare classical
and quantum models of computation you
know for this talk we're mainly going to
be interested in
the relationship between the randomized
classical query complexity
and the quantum query complexity both
with bounded error
okay so you know just um you know a very
kind of common example that i'm sure
you're familiar with
is the unstructured search problem where
we want to compute the logical or of the
bits
um you know if we've got some n-bit
string and we want to know the logical
or of the bits of that string
you know this is a problem for which we
can get a quadratic improvement
of the quantum query complexity over the
classical
uh query complexity whether it's
deterministic or randomized
all right um so uh we're also going to
be interested in
sort of the the setting of promise
problems so in the unstructured search
problem there's no
uh promise but in uh you know in general
we're going to be interested in problems
for which there might be some promise
that the input comes from some specific
set and this slide will also maybe
hopefully set to set
will help to set some of the notation
for the talk so we're going to be given
an
input string x specified again by a
black box
um that's you know it's an n character
string over some alphabet sigma
but um it's not necessarily an arbitrary
string
over you know over sigma rather it's
it's going to come from some set p
that could be much smaller so p is the
promise set we're promised that the
input comes
from the set p and now a query to the
black box uh
involves specifying an index i from one
through n
and then the black box will tell you
what is x sub i and our goal is
is going to be to compute some function
f x um where f
you know maps uh elements of this
promise set to zero one
okay and we want to do this using as few
queries as possible
all right so um if there's if there
isn't a non-trivial promise in other
words if x could be a completely
arbitrary string
over sigma so p is equal to sigma to the
n
then we say that f is a total function
and otherwise we'll say that it's a
partial function or that we have a
promise problem you know there's some
non-trivial promise
that we're told that that um you know x
comes from some you know specific subset
p
and this can really significantly affect
the difficulty of the problem so if p
is is special then the problem could be
a lot easier than if p is sigma to the n
you know in particular it's a well-known
result that if f is a total function
then you can have at most a polynomial
speed up
of uh quantum over classical computation
so it's it's now known i guess that you
can have
at most a fourth power speed up um and
so what this tells us is that promises
are really necessary for exponential
quantum speed up you know we can't have
exponential speed up for total functions
we have to have a promise
okay but just having some promise is not
enough of course it matters what the
promise is right if the promise is
somehow you know
there's one input that is that's
excluded that's not going to help so
much
um and in particular and and you know
more than that there are um
you know properties of promises that are
going to be sort of more or less helpful
um and uh and so we would like to
understand more about this what are sort
of you know promises that might allow
for exponential quantum speed up
um so so an example that that sort of
illustrates this nicely i think
and that's you know relevant to the kind
of properties that we're going to be
looking at in this talk
um is the the sort of relationship
between the collision problem and
simon's problem
so in the collision problem we're going
to be given an input x
um over you know um so x is an n
character string over some alphabet
sigma
now sigma can't can't be just 0 1 for
this problem sigma has to be
a larger alphabet like it has to have
size at least like on the order of
n for this for this problem to be well
defined um
and so here's the promise so i'm sort of
defining what this what this set p
is um you know x can either be a
one-to-one string which means that every
character of the string is distinct
or it can or it can be a two-to-one
string and that means that the
characters of that string come in pairs
um you know every sort of you know
character that appears in the string
appears exactly twice
and so that then we would say the string
is two to one and the collision problem
asks us to distinguish these two cases
do we have a one to one or a two to one
string
and uh you know it's well known that
there is polynomial quantum speed up for
this problem but only polynomial quantum
speed up
so classically you can do it with like
square root of n randomized queries
quantumly um you can get by with n to
the one-third
uh and that's the best you can do by
sort of the this well-known collision
lower bound of
aronson and she okay so that's an
example with polynomial quantum speed up
now notice that there is a promise in
this problem right the x is promised to
be either one to one or two to one
that's very special
right i mean most strings are neither
one to one nor two to one
but you know here it's there's the
promise you know although it's a very
non-trivial promise
it's not somehow a a promise that has
the right kind of structure to allow for
exponential quantum speed up
um but another example that sort of like
gives a
gives us a subset of the instances of
the collision problem
is what's called simon's problem so in
simon's problem
um we're going to do something you know
we're going to introduce some further
structure so let's identify the indices
of x so these these um you know indices
i
with strings of log n bits
and then the promise is going to be
either that you know the function is one
to one
or it's two to one but it's two to one
in a very particular way
so it's two to one where the pairs of
characters in the string
that are the same have indices that are
related by
xoring with some fixed string of log n
bits
right so there's some you know there's
some like fixed string
s um that somehow you use to
relate the the indices of you know
positions in the string
uh where the character is the same right
so so those are the sort of the the yes
instances of the problem and the no
instances are the one to one
uh you know the arbitrary one-to-one um
strings
right so um you know this is a um
you know an even more special promise
and it turns out that this promise is
enough
to allow for exponential quantum speed
up right so the the um it turns out that
classically the query complexity is
basically the same like a classical
computer can't
really uh you know make anything out of
this promise
um but a quantum computer can and it
takes the query complexity all the way
down to like logarithmic right so
there's
there's now an exponential gap between
the the classical and the quantum query
complexity
um so what's going on here or one thing
that's going on here
is that in the collision problem the the
the problem is permutation symmetric
like the promise set as well as the
function are permutation symmetric it
doesn't matter how you order
uh the indices but this bit structure to
these to these indices that's been
imposed in simon's problem
um is you know makes makes the problem
not permutation symmetric and you have
this like very highly structured promise
so you know that's that's um you know a
relevant fact and it's
um it's sort of related to something
much more general that's true
which is this kind of permutation
symmetry um is always enough to prevent
exponential quantum speed up okay
so so that's kind of the principle here
that permea that um symmetry can prevent
quantum speed up
um and and this is really quite a
general thing
so um let me say that a function is
permutation and variant
if you know for any permutation of the
indices so any pi
in sn um the promise set is
is permutation symmetric in the sense
that for any x in the promise set
x with its indices permuted by pi that's
what i mean here by x
composed of pi that's also going to be
an element of the promise set
so so this is just saying that the you
know the promise set is permutation
symmetric
and furthermore the function value is
the same if i permute the indices
according to any permutation right so
the collision problem is permutation
symmetric
in this sense um and it's a theorem that
for
actually for any permutation variant uh
problem
um the quantum and randomized query
complexities differ by at most a third
power
so this was was shown by xiu improving
an earlier result of erin syndrome
binance
um and so i think this raises a kind of
a very natural question
um which is you know what about other
symmetries right so this is about like
full permutation symmetry
but what if you have you know less
symmetry than that what is what is sort
of
you know enough symmetry that is you
know significant enough to prevent
exponential quantum speed up i mean i
mean first of all are there any
symmetries other than
the full permutation symmetry that are
enough to prevent exponential quantum
speed up and you know if so what are
they
and you know i think this is a nice
question from the standpoint of looking
for
um you know quantum algorithms because
you know we would like to know
sort of um what to avoid right i mean
what are the what are the things that
will prevent exponential quantum speed
up
you know those are that sort of tells us
where not to look um for
for exponential quantum speedups okay
and a kind of particular motivating
symmetry that's going to be sort of like
the main
um sort of um i mean it's going to be
sort of an important object in this work
is this notion of graph symmetry um and
maybe this maybe this also helps to give
an example of sort of a symmetry that's
less than
full permutation symmetry that would be
uh you know of interest
so um in a uh so so we're going to call
a problem a graph property
if um you know the input describes a
graph so it's going to say basically
what edges are present in the graph
we've got n vertices and the input tells
us what edges are there
um and then the property depends only on
the isomorphism class of the graph
right so we have n vertices you could
imagine specifying the graph by like
you know you have these these vertices
numbered one through n and then the
input just tells you which pairs of
vertices
um are adjacent but to be a graph
property
you know it should sort of only depend
on the picture it shouldn't depend on
how the
um you know how the vertices are
numbered right it should only depend on
the isomorphism class
um and so you know this is just sort of
the same thing kind of written out
algebraically right so um but the input
again just specifies what edges are
present in the graph
so um you know when i when i think about
permuting the vertices in some way
right that's a permutation of n things
but the input
has sort of like n choose two bits in it
right so those n choose two things the
these bits that are telling us whether
an edge is present or not
um those are going those are getting
permuted in some way that's
that's you know carried over from the
permutation of the vertices
right specifically like the way i
permute the edge uv is that
uv gets mapped to pi of u comma pi of v
right so there's only like n factorial
permutations of the
uh you know of the vertices but there's
like you know
there would be like n choose two
factorial ways of permuting you know the
bits that specify all of the edges so
somehow this is really much less than
like
full um you know full symmetry of of the
input
it's a very special kind of class of
symmetries
okay uh okay good
so um so we're going to be interested in
sort of what we can say
about the query complexity of graph
properties that have this you know kind
of
much smaller symmetry group and um
we're also going to be interested in a
sort of another thing about the way we
could define the promise
in the problem which is in the setting
of property testing
so in property testing um we we have
some property that
that on yes instances is going to be
satisfied but then we have some
additional
um you know feature of the promise which
is that if you're a no
instance you should be very far from any
yes instance
right so in property testing and you
know this this is a like a fairly strong
thing and can sometimes allow for much
much faster algorithms right so you
either have a yes instance or
you're promised that your instance is
very far from any yes instance
right so we could talk about for example
like you know we're given some
some graph that's either a bipartite
graph or it's very far from a bipartite
graph meaning you would have to change
many of the edges to make it bipartite
and then you can ask something about the
the
cost of testing that property on a black
box input
and actually this setting has been
widely studied in you know
classical as well as quantum computing
and it was shown for example by
um uh goldrick and ron um that
um you know there are some problems for
which um
uh so so i mean i should say i mean like
for for many problems actually you can
you can
do things really dramatically faster in
this property testing scenario than if
you didn't have this big gap between yes
and no instances
but there are some problems for which
you don't get such a significant
advantage
uh you know when you try to test at
least classically um
and so for example if you're given a
graph as specified
by an adjacency list representation and
let's say it's a bounded degree graph so
for every vertex you know it can have at
most
a constant number of other neighbors
let's say
um then you know they showed that the
randomized um
query complexity of testing property
like bipartiteness
is like the square root of n they
actually showed this also for testing
expansion
um and so you know we did some work on
this um
uh quite some time ago now where we
considered quantum algorithms for these
properties in the same setting
and we showed that actually for these
these two problems of testing
bipartiteness and testing expansion
we could get a polynomial quantum speed
up so taking things down from the square
root of n to the cube root of n
um and actually we showed that you could
get at most of polynomial speed up
although we still don't know how much
speed up is possible
for the problem of testing expansion and
actually we still don't know for
bipartiteness like we don't have a proof
that you can't get an exponential
um you know quantum speed up for testing
bipartiteness in the in the adjacency
list model
um so you know but but this result about
testing expansion
you know kind of suggests i don't know
maybe maybe these are problems for which
you can get only
polynomial quantum speed up right that's
the case here and maybe that's true kind
of more generally because of the nature
of the symmetry
of these problems right
so um you know maybe we could rule out
testing
uh you know getting an exponential speed
up for testing bipartiteness in that way
and maybe more generally uh you know
maybe it's never possible to get
exponential quantum speed up for um you
know for testing graph properties
because the
because of the sort of you know symmetry
of these problems
and so we sort of i guess maybe kind of
like implicitly posed this question and
it was also mentioned in this paper of
montenarro and dewolfe you know nice
survey article that they wrote
uh in 2013. so um
one thing that i want to emphasize is
that there are sort of different models
of access to a graph so here we're
talking about the adjacency list
representation
um but you can also have other natural
models like
i mean one that's that's used very often
is the adjacency matrix representation
where um you know there's a there's a
bit that specifies
uh you know for any given pair of
vertices whether they're adjacent or not
um and that's the adjacency matrix
representation and you know the answer
could could be quite different depending
upon which
um which representation you you take and
actually i mean
this is this is sort of the case as
we'll see
okay so let me now sort of uh you know
summarize what the main results are and
then as i said i want to sort of take
take the um you know spend the most time
focusing on one of these
these three results that's the one that
we um you know
worked on there at the at the simons
institute
okay so the first thing we show is that
actually in the adjacency matrix model
right where the black box describes
basically you know the adjacency
matrix right so we have uh we have this
like you know n by n adjacency matrix
there's a bit
uh for every pair of vertices that tells
you um you know whether those two
vertices are adjacent or not
um then uh you can have at most a sixth
power
speed up of of quantum over cl over
classical query complexity over the
randomized
query complexity and in fact more
generally than this we show
that you can have it most of power 3k
speed up for k
uniform hypergraph properties right so k
equals two is the
um you know the sort of case of graphs
uh cables one i guess is the
is the sort of you know fully symmetric
case that was sort of already handled by
xiu but you can also consider you know
three regular hyper graphs four regular
hypergrass et cetera
the sort of the bound gets looser and
looser but um uh
anyway this is this is what we show and
so this shows that in some sense this is
another class of symmetries that prevent
exponential quantum speed up right graph
properties are somehow
um you know still enough even though
there's much less symmetry than full
permutation symmetry
uh it's still enough um you know to
prevent exponential quantum speed up
we also show that in some sense we don't
sort of like
kind of completely show this but we we
sort of um go some way towards showing
that in some sense this is like
um the only way of preventing
exponential quantum speed up
with symmetry um and so we do this by
sort of considering more general
permutation groups that could be the
symmetries of
functions that you might want to compute
in query complexity
and we show we show that for a class of
permutation groups that are what's
called primitive
that you can sort of characterize
whether speed up is or is not possible
in terms of
a property of those permutation groups
called its base size
and um yeah we sort of show that if the
base size is in some sense large you can
have it most polynomial quantum speed up
if it's small then um you know it's
possible to have speed up there exists a
function that has superpolynomial
quantum speed up and furthermore um you
can sort of show that
um this this large case kind of
the only the only um way that this can
happen is to have
a hypergraph symmetry so so so in some
sense the only
symmetries that prevent significant
speed up are these hypergraph symmetries
now this is just for primitive
permutation groups which are in some
sense building blocks of general
permutation groups but
but somehow if you look in detail at the
way that they can be used to compose
general permutation groups
um the thing that we show is not quite
enough to kind of fully characterize
speed ups for general permutation groups
but it's but it's somehow close there's
a nice open question there to somehow
you know complete this classification
okay but then the sort of last of our
results um
looks at the the case of um the
adjacency list model
right so so you know this result is
about the adjacency matrix model
but what if instead we have let's say a
bounded degree graph
that's specified by an adjacency list
right so in the adjacency list model
you can specify to the black box a
particular vertex that you care about
and the black box will tell you what are
its neighbors you know either you sort
of
give the index of one of its neighbors
um and the and the black box tells you
what is that what is the neighbor with
that index or maybe
if we're talking about boundary degree
graphs it's it's the same up to a
constant factor
to just say that the black box tells you
all of the neighbors
um so um you know what we um
what we're interested in is you know
also what is the quantum query
complexity
of um graph properties in this adjacency
list model
you know because for example we would
like to understand the quantum query
complexity of testing bipartiteness or
testing expansion
um you know which are problems that are
defined in this setting
um and so um you know what we show is
that actually
um it is possible to get exponential
speedups in this model
and in fact it's even possible to get
exponential speedups
in the setting of property testing right
so in property testing you have this
like very strong promise
that the the property whatever it is is
either satisfied or it's far from being
satisfied
right which again means that you have to
change a large fraction of the edges
if you're given a no instance um to turn
it into a yes instance
right so that's a very strong uh
property which means that in some sense
you can have you know
you would expect to be able to have
pretty fast classical algorithms
um as well as quantum algorithms but it
turns out that you know somehow you can
still have a big gap
right so we give an example of a problem
that
um you know that has this has such an
exponential uh
quantum speed up and so this is the
thing that sort of um
you know i i kind of uh discussed in the
open problem session
at the at the assignments meeting um we
we sort of knew that this was possible
for
graph properties generally but it was
unclear whether you could sort of have a
graph property testing problem
for which this for which this was the
case but it turns out that even that is
true
that even for graph property testing in
the adjacency list model you can have
an exponential quantum speed up okay
so um yeah that's the um that those are
sort of the main results and what i want
to do in the rest of the time is just
talk a little bit about this
last result but i don't know maybe this
is a good point uh to maybe just pause
just to see if there's any questions to
clarify the setting or what the results
are
um if there's any questions i'm happy to
answer them
so very quick question andrew uh so the
uh the full permanent permutation
symmetry
what does it correspond to in this
picture is it complete graph or
something like that
um so if you if you're talking about
graph properties then like
full permutation symmetry simply doesn't
arise right i mean
the you know the permutations act on the
vertices
and a permutation of the vertices
induces a structured permutation of the
possible edges
right so there's like you know n
factorial ways of permuting the vertices
um but you know whether the graph is the
complete graph
or it's you know some very sparse graph
um
still the way the the sort of edges or
non-edges would be permuted is the same
right that somehow
you know uv gets mapped to pi of u pi of
v
and you know if it's the complete graph
okay that's always there but the
you know the um the symmetry is like
it's not a property of the graph as such
it's a property of the
you know because you don't know what the
graph is i mean the graph could maybe be
anything
um it's a property of the you know the
fact that we're talking about graph
properties right it's
i don't know if that if that helps
thanks okay great
awesome okay great so yeah maybe i'll go
on and um
just tell you a little bit about this um
you know this problem of um sort of
showing an exponential separation
for a graph property testing problem in
the adjacency list model right in the
adjacency matrix model
we showed that that's not possible uh
but but in the adjacency list model we
showed that it is i'm going to talk a
little bit about
how we're able to show that it's proper
that it's possible
[Music]
okay so the kind of main tool in showing
this is this
or the maybe the you know the seed for
for constructing an example that shows
this
is this example of exponential speed up
by quantum lock from uh
you know rather old paper that we wrote
um
and you know the idea of of this um
example is to sort of show that quantum
analogs of random walks these these
coherent quantum walks on graphs
can solve some problems dramatically
faster than is possible
you know with any classical algorithm um
so we so in as in this paper we defined
this you know so-called welded trees
problem
where we're given an adjacency list
black box for a graph that looks like
this
we have two binary trees that are that
are um
joined together by this weld that's like
um
a random cycle that alternates between
the the leaves of the two trees and
eventually comes back to where it
started
um so that every vertex here except for
the entrance and the exit every vertex
has degree three
um and so locally the graph kind of
looks like uh
you know just a three regular binary
tree there are of course cycles if you
go to sort of like large enough scales
there can even be small cycles but
they're sort of rare
um and uh anyway so the graph you know
has this structure
and now the question is you know um uh
given an adjacency list black box for
this thing and given
you know the initially the entrance um
find the exit right you want to somehow
find your way through this graph
to the exit vertex and you can imagine
that the way that this adjacency list
black box refers to the to the vertices
is that it gives them
names that are much longer than you
would need to sort of minimally specify
them
so you can really only hope to explore
the graph locally like if you start from
the entrance
you know if you just come up with some
random name it's probably not the name
of any vertex right so really all you
can do is sort of
use this adjacency list black box to
explore the graph locally
and now uh you know you want to you want
to understand how fast it is how fast
you can find the exit
and so for a um you know with a quantum
algorithm
you can run a quantum walk on this graph
which is some coherent quantum process
that you can show we'll find this exit
vertex in polynomial time
okay but on the other hand a randomized
classical algorithm you can prove
needs exponential time to find the exit
basically because to a classical
algorithm this graph kind of looks like
an infinite binary tree somehow it can
never get oriented it never gets any
information
that allows it to sort of you know move
in the right direction
of the exit um so
this you know this sounds like actually
a lot like what i'm talking about right
because
there's an adjacency less black box and
there's an exponential separation
right but this is not an example of an
exponential separation for a graph
property
because you know we've given you sort of
an entrance point into the graph right
we've specified a particular vertex of
the graph
and so we've sort of break broken the
symmetry by doing that right
the graph property really sort of
depends in some way on how the vertices
are labeled
so how do we sort of you know modify
this so that it's actually a graph
property
um well so there's a kind of a fairly
straightforward way of turning this into
an exponential speed up for a graph
property
by just modifying the the instance a
little bit um
you know what you can do is somehow like
decorate the entrance with some large
binary tree um that if you choose uh you
know
a random vertex of the graph like you'll
probably find something over here
um and then you know from this thing you
can create um
you can sort of like find your way to
the entrance and then you can run the
ordinary
uh you know uh quantum walk algorithm to
find your way uh to the exit
um but you know if uh um
uh if you have a classical algorithm
then it's gonna be hard for sort of like
the same reason that it was hard
in the original case so yeah maybe in
the interest of time because i see like
we're
we're supposed to only go for half an
hour um um
yeah let me not let me not sort of read
all these words but just say i mean i
think i already said what the main idea
is that by
that by somehow you know expanding the
graph a little bit
you can you can uh make it a regular an
ordinary graph property so you're not
given the name of this entrance vertex
or of any particular vertex you're just
given
an adjacency list black box for this
graph
but nevertheless you can you can sort of
come up with a quantum algorithm
that will sort of distinguish the two
classes of graphs uh
you know fast whereas classically you'll
still need exponential time to
distinguish them
however and so this is where things sort
of were at the beginning of the the open
problem session uh there at the simons
institute
um this is a graph property now but it's
not a graph property testing problem
because um you know what we define here
are two classes of instances that are
very close to each other
right we're going to consider here we're
just going to change things locally at
the exit by either adding or not adding
these three marker vertices
so you can change just these three edges
to change between yes and no instances
right so this is not a graph property
testing problem
even though it's a graph property and so
um
what we want to do to make this problem
um you know into a graph property
testing problem
is um to come up with some kind of a
structure that can still be
you know sort of efficiently understood
by a quantum algorithm
but um so that a classical algorithm
will still have a hard time
distinguishing things
um you know even when it's given the
promise that the no instances are very
far from the s instances right so you're
not allowed to have these like
instances that are hard to distinguish
from the from the s instances
only because you changed you know a few
vertices in sort of a small place
um and so the the sort of construction
um that we
that we use um sort of builds upon this
welded trees idea
but by taking many copies of these
welded tree graphs with these antenna
these antennas these large binary trees
attached to the two roots
um and then with some additional edges
added uh to somehow um
you know provide some advice that sort
of tells you about whether
a vertex is in what we call a body this
sort of central thing
or as in one of these antennas these
binary trees that are added
uh to the left and to the right um
so i don't know how strict are we being
on time can i just take like sort of two
or three minutes to say a few more words
about this
yeah yeah a few minutes should be fine
we already have a few questions
okay great all right thanks okay yeah so
let me just say a few words about sort
of
the two main sides of this one is to
show that quantumly you know we can sort
of uh distinguish the yes and the no
instances
and the other is that you know
classically it's it's hard
right so um on the sort of quantum side
um we sort of consider this setting
where you're given this
untrusted advice that sort of tells you
whether a vertex
is um what we call a weld vertex so
that's a vertex you know right here in
the middle
it's at the place where the two binary
trees are are welded together
um or not and that information is
encoded in
you know so there are these these edges
that are added they're sort of special
edges they're like
we have like two two parallel edges um
that are added between
vertices between an antenna and a body
and they're going to be connected to um
they're going to be connected to an
instance of this graph
that has a parity of these so there are
these circles that
that you see here at these root vertices
um the parity is either going to be even
or odd depending upon whether you
connect to something
that's a weld or a non-weld vertex so
this is some way of encoding
in the structure of the graph you know
some advice that's going to tell you
something about whether you're
you're a weld or a non-weld vertex now
if you would have that advice and you
would really be able to know what that
advice says
um then even a classical computer would
be able to test the property of whether
you're
whether you have an instance that looks
like this or whether you're far from an
instance that looks like this
right so um you know we sort of defined
some tests that use
these are just classical tests that kind
of use non-backtracking walks
to sort of uh check that certain
properties of the of the graph hold
um such that you know like yes instances
of the problem will definitely pass
and no instances are likely to be to be
detected
okay so you could you could even do this
classically if you had this advice
but the thing is you're not going to
have this advice given to you directly i
mean there's no advice in this problem
anyway
and the advice is advice is really just
encoded in the presence
of these edges these advice edges and
these are edges that can be used by a
quantum algorithm because
using the ability to sort of solve this
glued trees problem
you can sort of make use of these of
these edges to figure out whether you
have a weld or a non-weld vertex and
then you can use that
information in this kind of classical
test with advice
um and uh and so quantumly um you can
sort of unlock the advice
and make use of it but classically you
can't and so like well
certainly it's not obvious how to how to
run this tester and there
and solve the problem but what we show
is that actually
the problem is really hard like not only
can you not unlock the advice
but the problem really still takes
exponential time classically
and the way that we show this is
basically by constructing some specific
set of no instances where we just
sort of self-weld the binary trees
these are instances that are legitimate
no instances they're far from any yes
instance
and we show that even these specific no
instances are hard for
a classical computer to distinguish from
the legitimate yes instances
and this basically follows by sort of
the same kind of hardness argument
um that we give for the um you know for
the for the ordinary um
glute trees problem okay so i'm a little
bit over time let me
maybe just stop there but say that um
you know there are still lots of open
problems
uh you know related to this you know
there are some interesting open
questions about sort of the
the sort of adjacency matrix type stuff
kind of understanding
you know what the best possible
separations are uh you know for various
kinds of problems um and you know as i
mentioned there's this problem about
sort of characterizing the permutation
groups that allow for super polynomial
speed up
which we don't yet kind of really fully
characterize um
and i think there are also some nice
questions related to this adjacency list
uh you know stuff that i that i sort of
talked about at the end um
you know the problem that that i
described is of course completely
artificial and contrived to show a
separation
uh you know i think it's a nice question
to sort of think about whether
these this um this kind of thing could
lead to an actually you know useful
uh quantum algorithm in particular the
problem of testing bipartiteness in the
adjacency list model is still open
i think it would be very surprising if
there were an exponential speed up for
that problem but actually showing
you know one way or the other i think
would be would be really nice
um and sort of in general better
understanding you know what are the
kinds of graph property testing problems
for which we can or cannot have
exponential speed ups
is i think a nice question okay sorry to
go
a bit over and let me let me stop there
thank you for the talk now we have a few
minutes for questions so
please speak up if you have a question
um i have a question sure
in your open problem for k strictly
greater than one what is
p oh sorry this is probably for
oh what is p
that is a good question maybe this is
meant to be k
[Music]
i'm actually not sure off the top of my
head what i meant by that
i i think it is k i'm not entirely sure
yeah um
i also think that we can actually
improve this now
using the recent um
there's the work by stop and glue which
gives a
larger query complexity separation so it
might be more like
um p to the one minus epsilon or
something
okay or i guess k to the one minus
epsilon
but i'm not entirely sure
[Music]
yeah yeah i think this p is k it's for
this is for like you know
i think at one point in our paper we
talked about p uniform hyper graphs so
it's um
uh yeah sorry for the confusion i guess
this i guess this p is k
uh yeah but that's interesting i guess
but this is i guess uh
like a fairly small improvement i guess
right i mean i guess there's still
there's still quite a large uh gap
between sort of um
the best separations that we know and
the and the um
sort of the lower bound
there's a question in q a by iron
what prevents any speed up for adjacency
matrix model
uh is the question the question is about
like the mechanism for preventing the
speed up
i mean i guess um
let me let me uh make a list
just maybe
mean it's um
yeah it's a question
if the question is yeah sort of like
what is the mechanism for preventing the
speed up i think it's
um like i don't know i mean what is
preventing the speed up is the symmetry
um and uh you know
i mean if the question is about what the
proof looks like
um i guess it's um
you know it it essentially is a
generalization of the sort of like the
the k
equals one proof you know we sort of use
um
sort of shyu's method but sort of show
how you can um
sort of like effectively embed the um
yeah the sort of like full permutation
symmetry but with some loss
you know into the into the kind of
setting where you have
let's say a graph symmetry or a
hypergraph symmetry um
but i don't know if that's really a
satisfying answer to the question
okay thank you i think that helps okay
all right thanks
you're asking here whether it should be
where it should be between three and two
that's right
you probably know better than i do i
don't know i mean uh i don't have i
don't think i have a
an informed conjecture um
i mean you know i guess there was you
know i guess there was all this sort of
like um
you know for for sort of like um
um i guess for
like for total functions there was this
you know question about whether you
could have you know super quadratic
speed ups and i guess you and others
worked on this
and sort of showed you know examples of
you know of super quadratic speedups
which was i guess surprising at the time
so
um i guess if the same thing plays out
in this context you know maybe
i don't know maybe maybe you can do
better than this but it's a different
setting so maybe
yeah i really really just don't know i
don't have
any intuition for this really
thanks
i wanted to ask about the status of
monotone graph property
properties like um do we know any
partial results at least in this
direction
no i don't think so i mean i guess what
what would a partial result look like
i mean um
[Music]
i mean i guess this is you know i guess
the reason that maybe we
we um you know be interesting to think
about monotone graph properties is that
you know
i guess bipartiteness or maybe you have
to think about
non-bipartiteness but anyway you can you
can sort of have a sort of a monotone
graph property
and maybe this could be a maybe you know
a way of somehow you know
showing and i guess also for expansion
right i mean i guess it's it again has
this issue that's
this um you know kind of um a character
that somehow if you add edges you can
only make the graph you know kind of
more expanding
um uh so so maybe that could be sort of
a feature that sort of like
um distinguishes you know these kind of
you know wacky cases you know certainly
the thing that we constructed is
is non-monotone and maybe that could be
the thing that uh you know distinguishes
it from
from you know uh more pedestrian things
like
like um bipartiteness and expansion but
um i think that's i don't think there's
anything
i don't think there's anything more that
we know about that mean i suppose
another thing is just to look you know
one could do is just to look at specific
examples of monotone graph properties
and try to understand
you know the the the classical and
quantum query complexity of testing them
um you know the the sort of the the
lower bound for testing expansion
uh you know quantumly is really like you
know
not at all straightforward and uses like
very specific properties of expansion
um so um something that sort of you know
considered
um let's say monotone properties more
generally would have to look
presumably very different
so there's a question in q a yes i see
yeah thank you so to connect the
permutation symmetry to physical systems
is the permutation symmetry
in the total wave function of
indistinguishable particles a reason
that prevents exponential quantum
speedups
for electronic structure problems um
i mean i i don't i don't know of a
connection along those lines
i mean i guess the um um
yeah i mean the you know in in the sort
of you know stuff that i talked about
here the symmetry is the symmetry uh
sort of of the
uh of the inputs you know whereas in the
electronic structure problems it's like
a sort of you know
underlying property of the quantum state
it's like a property of the state space
that the
um that the thing that you're looking
for lives in um
so i think it's really it's really quite
different i guess i i don't i don't
really see a connection between these
two things
if there were one it would be really
interesting
okay well thank thank you andrew once
again
in the interest of time let's and
keeping that schedule let's uh
uh let's move to robin's talk
so yeah it's our next speaker is robin